this video is sponsored by keeps which
means we will have an ad from them
somewhere in the middle of the video
hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
another q a this one is a gaming q a i
also do personal q as we kind of like
alternate between the two every couple
of weeks leave whatever questions you
have for either of them below and i will
sort through them for the next q a also
yeah my office is kind of coming
together slowly it's not really i still
have so much to do
but it's going to be um full of cool god
of war stuff pretty soon
i will unbox these big beautiful boxes
this is from prime one i'm so excited
because i do like my content creation
work stuff right here which is like
streaming the youtube videos and then my
um sony santa monica studio work i do in
that corner so i'm gonna make that all
very god of war e and i'm very excited
about it but yes the reverb is certainly
still a thing because there's still just
not really very much in this room first
question is from french user 110 and i'm
glad to answer this question
um they said hey i saw that you played
dying like too early just wondering when
that content was going to go up a great
question i did get to play dying light
to a couple of weeks ago for five six
hours quite a while captured the whole
thing since i moved um i've just not
been able to render the video file i i
screwed up something with my pc in the
move it has been fixed so that video i'm
hoping to have up either this week or
next week i just have to have the time
to edit
all of that video footage thankfully my
pc can handle it now so the problem has
been solved so yes if you would if you
have any questions for the dying light 2
video i did put a post up on instagram
but you could also put them in the
comments below
and i will be able to include them as
well but yeah i can talk about
everything i played so i will do that
shortly the next question is from
jack williams artwork who said hey alana
i know you've spoken a couple of times
about how game of the year voting works
i saw your recent tech talk video thank
you i do now have a tick tock
and i was wondering if you could explain
the difference between voting for
various organizations
okay you want the truth
about
game of the year voting i can give it to
you for multiple organizations i've been
on the jury for the game awards as in
jeff keeley's game awards uh i've did
voting at ign i've done voting for
baftas for indiecade i think they've
been maybe three more um and they all do
have different approaches and i have
spoken about this across videos but i
don't think i've ever titled a video
with it so maybe we'll use this in the
title this is what we'll jump into here
so if you are talking about the game
awards specifically um yes i have been
on that voting jury
three years i think i wasn't this year
and i wasn't last year and frankly i
don't think i will be again
now that i work for a first party
playstation studio that would be pretty
weird the game awards voting is the most
hands-off of all of the juries that i've
been on the way that it works is
various outlets um from a lot of
different backgrounds different
countries to different nationalities are
asked to be on part of the board and
then uh are called upon to before a
certain date submit games that they want
for each category the way that funhouse
and ign did it were actually pretty
similar at ign
i think you're only allowed to vote if
you had reviewed a game that year so it
wasn't just like the whole company would
vote it was specifically people in
editorial i hope i'm remembering that
correctly at funhouse it was all of the
um main producers at the time who would
vote and both companies actually did it
pretty similarly for fun house say it
was six people or so i think it was
elise would write each of the categories
just into an excel spreadsheet and then
we would put in whatever games we
thought
fit in those completely independently of
everybody else who was writing in that
spreadsheet and then elise would take
whichever one was voted for the most and
send it off to the game awards ign i
believe we did google forms so similar
thing everybody just kind of
puts in whatever they think should be
nominated and then i think it probably
was dan stapleton who's the executive
editor of reviews at ign would get the
results send them off to jeff keely that
is how you get your nominees it's just
whatever people think to submit it's not
a tremendous
um difference there between
that and any other award studio like the
baftas this year i'm not currently on
any jury for next year's voting but
because i have been previously they did
reach out to me and ask hey what are
some games do you feel like should be
nominated in these categories um and so
i sent them a list of games so the
nominees are certainly just like
the most popular suggestions
from a lot of people i think indicates
specifically and a couple of the other
uh more indie focused award shows
actually
are user submitted um or dev submitted
would would be accurate they're actually
submitted by devs so from there
um
where the game awards is concerned you
would then get a list back of each of
the games that successfully made it into
the nominee rounds which would be an
aggregate of every single outlet
submitting the games that they wanted to
nominate and the most popular ones being
chosen and then we would go through an
order again in whatever internal system
you want to use before you actually send
it back which would be our pick for game
of the year of the five and yeah again i
believe both funhouse and ign did this
pretty independently so even the people
who are in the same room working for the
same company um didn't necessarily have
a lot of discussion
it was just
even those people independently would
submit it again i haven't been at ign
for like four years so i really hope i'm
remembering that correct and that's
basically the way that the game awards
functions is
a lot of people who make up an outlet
generally there are a couple of
individual content creators but not many
just throw a bunch of names in
um they don't have a jury that sits down
and discusses things there's no
guarantee that anybody has finished any
of the games that they're nominating
anyone can vote for anything for any
reason they like as a result of that
system um the game awards is very much a
popularity contest it is generally going
to go to whichever game uh the most
people played it's always gotta be games
a lot of people have heard of um because
there are so many outlets and because
there's no deliberation between the jury
at all um and it really is just like
these people picked this for whatever
reason they like you don't even have to
agree on the reason uh because yeah the
jury doesn't talk at all there's no
communication whatsoever i think a lot
of the criticism where people like oh
the game ward's jury's so biased it's
like well okay a yes everybody's biased
i certainly think that there is
a bias in all awards shows including you
know your golden globes and your oscars
and even mtv
that favors a very specific kind of
thing things like the oscars tend to
favor a very specific kind of film and
the game awards tend to favor a very
specific kind of game which in my
opinion is generally one that is very
heartfelt it has like a very gripping
story that's the thing that people tend
to carry with them and give that onus of
game of the year so yes of course that
is a bias um but it's not a bias that
involves any collusion it kind of can't
these people do not communicate at all
they wouldn't even know each other there
are hundreds potentially thousands of
people who would have input on what
games get nominated even from each
outlet so it's just a very big thing
with a whole lot of people and the
people who are on that jury get 90
of the voting power the public gets the
other 10 and i have seen some really
strange criticism of it um we interrupt
your regularly scheduled q a programming
to talk about keeps keeps is an online
subscription service that helps men keep
their hair with keeps you can get
quality expert care without ever
visiting a doctor's office or pharmacy
but all treatment plans are still doctor
recommended and delivered straight to
your door at about half the cost of a
traditional pharmacy keeps has a full
network of expert medical advisors
prescribers and care specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality and each treatment plan comes
with a full year of unlimited messaging
so you can connect with your prescribing
doctor about anything anytime so whether
you're looking to prevent hair loss
stimulate hair growth or just take
better care of the hair that you have
keeps has you covered in addition to
clinically proven treatments keeps also
has an award-winning all-natural
thickening shampoo and conditioner
system and it keeps physicians will help
you select the right products and
treatments for your specific condition
and hair goals easily subscribe to keeps
and get refill reminders so you'll never
run low on the products you need to take
care of your hair hair loss stops with
keeps to get 50 off your first order go
to keeps.com alana pierce or click the
link in the description to receive 50
off your first order that's k-e-e-p-s
slash alana pierce like people
complaining that it's not publicly voted
and that it should be and that it means
it's like keeping trash that it's not
the reason that a lot of these award
shows again the game awards is not the
only one to do it a lot of them do it um
generally all of them do it all award
shows for every entertainment media does
it generally unless they are literally
called people's choice awards the reason
that exists to me seems very obvious
uh it's because
they want to make sure that people are
voting who are actually playing a lot of
games
you can have people who are hardcore
gamers but who only play fifa every
single year and thus you would only have
fifa nominated for game of the year
every single year i just saw this uh
instagram story thing that ign did
where they pulled how many people played
certain games let me find it have you
played death loop 87 said no
have you played death's door 96 said no
have you played resident evil village 63
said no have you paid
have you played back full blood 73 said
no have you played forza horizon 5 is 65
percent said no psychonauts 2 91 said no
have you played it takes two 79 said no
ratchet and clank 77 said no and of all
of those uh ratchet is the only one that
less people played that got voted for
um as the preferred game and i just feel
like that's really indicative of like
i've played every single one of those
games um
and the fact that some of those are so
low
is why the general public is not
generally on a voting board because then
it's going to be even more skewed to
popularity than it already is if 96 of
the general public hasn't played death's
door which the game's really good
it's a shame that it didn't get
noticed
more at the awards show anyway then
that's 96 people who clearly aren't
going to nominate it or vote for it
whereas if you throw it to people who
work in the industry professionally and
it is part of their jobs to be on top of
the games that come out and be playing
more of them it means that it's a little
bit more of a guarantee that every
single year it's not just going to be
whichever is the most marketed highest
selling game which is virtually always
going to be a call of duty
or a fifa and yeah i've seen criticism
suggesting that this is some kind of
corruption and i certainly don't agree i
do think the awards jury is going to
have bias because all humans have bias
the general public would have the same
level of bias potentially in different
ways but it would still be biased but
yes focusing on people who work in the
industry is to make sure that they have
played more games but again there is no
guarantee that they have and no
guarantee that they've finished any of
them because i don't know how you would
enforce that without paying them and
without like assuming they don't already
have demanding jobs and lives and all
that so i've also been on the baftas
jury and the baptist jury
required our entire jury the jury was
different for every category which is a
thing that i really liked i was on best
debut game um i was initially asked to
be on the narrative one being that i
technically work in
narrative design in game development
but
a game
that my name was in the credits of was
nominated and thus they had to remove me
because that would be a conflict of
interest so i was then on debut game
there's a whole bunch of different
people uh who came together
they give us the nominees we do not
choose what to nominate
i assume the board of the bafta chooses
the nominees we have to play each of
them um the idea is that you do your
very best to finish them if you can't
you just have to at least try them
enough to feel like you have an opinion
so you do have to have played every game
and then you have a zoom call for
several hours where you get together and
you pick which games you are going to
pick and you discuss what you liked and
didn't like do you hear each other out
and that's really helpful because you
can hear downsides or positives of
things that you wouldn't have thought
about otherwise but then when that whole
conversation is done it kind of becomes
clear which games everybody likes and
why and and you have a different
perspective because you're sharing the
whole group's perspectives um and for
the record all of those jurors are
people who work in game development i
think they maybe occasionally have some
people from games media but it is
largely game development and then at the
end of the call you go on to vote on the
bafta website um and it's based on a
score so you can vote for your first
your second and your third and i think
you give them points if i remember
correctly but it's anonymous so you
actually don't know what everybody else
voted for so if somebody tried very hard
to convince you you still wouldn't
actually have to vote for whatever they
suggested indicate was pretty similar
except without the anonymity um and
for ndk they had discussions but i
couldn't join any of them because they
were at an exact point in time where i
have a meeting for my day job
every week but you get the nominees you
assign yourself to play a number of them
um and then for everyone else you kind
of explain what you thought of them so
the ndk jury very much has to trust each
other so i would write like a mini
review for everyone here's why i think
this um and then of the games that i was
like i really think this one should be
nominated for something i would also
read anybody else's reviews that are
extremely glowing about other things and
then made sure i played those games so
by the time we get to the nomination
point for each category
i have played the games that are
nominated um and we do the same thing
ranking by numbers but it's all publicly
listed and then somebody goes in
aggregates those and chooses which wins
in each category but you can outright
nominate something as well so it's a
very general consensus kind of thing so
yeah the game awards is the most
hands-off um i think ign the way they
did their internal one was also uh
google form which i believe anyone who
worked at the company could participate
in i don't imagine they let the sales
team participate in it
just something that i feel is really
worth noting is that the sales team
and the editorial team are very very
very separate i've seen people be like
oh it's a coincidence that
you know this game that gets this
advertising budget won this award
there is no way that any of the people
who are on the voting side at ign would
have any idea what sales deals are
coming up those teams do not talk they
are so separate they're not even allowed
to communicate ask to ask hey lana have
you played ac valhalla
i have not
um i've actually intentionally not not
played ac valhalla
because working at santa monica studio
obviously ragnarok is based in norse
mythology and i wanted to make the
active decision not to consume other
norse content i think someone at the
studio may have even suggested this to
me i don't remember
um but i didn't want to see other
examples of it so that nothing that i
thought would be influenced in any way
by it like i don't want to be influenced
in a way that's like oh this game's done
this though or in a way that's like oh
that's cool what if we did that so i
will not play ac valhalla actually um
while santa monica studio is actively
working on god of war ragnarok adam
prince said you have a question what is
the most underrated game in your opinion
and which would be the most overrated
i think i answered this my most recent q
a that i feel like the words underrated
and overrated
like are just very overused um so with
that context
a thing that i will admit that i don't
love those terms
it generally just means you like
something less or more than what you
think is the general consensus you know
i think that dragon's dogma is
criminally
underrated but even then it probably is
highly rated i just don't feel like it's
spoken about it's a 78 on metacritic so
it's not like it's really underrated
it's more than like i know i would rate
it higher than that i would totally rate
it higher than that i'd give it like a
nine it's more that i just feel like not
enough people talk about dragon's dogma
specifically darker risen was actually
the one that i preferred
in relation to how good i feel like that
game is i really love it and then the
most overrated i'm trying to think of
what's a game people really like that i
don't like that much i've never liked
the gameplay in bioshock a lot of great
things about both of those games all
three of them in fact but uh bioshock is
probably the most popular franchise that
while i have played all of them
i have never felt like i love any of
those games as much as a lot of other
people do there are things that i think
are brilliant about them but i don't
like
gush of the bioshock
like a lot of other people do and this
video is already really long so we're
gonna leave it there everybody
thank you all for watching remember that
you can find out more about keeps by
clicking the link in the description
below thank you again to them for
sponsoring these for such a long time i
appreciate it and i will see you guys
next time bye